i love to be with
boys of course because i'm boy crazy
and i like to go crazy and i like to
party
[Music]
the r word hurts my feelings
i gotta stop right here
called us in the old world
because it's not cool to use it
don't you at all that's in bullets
for good
we don't want to hear that word take
that word out of your mouth and change
into respect just
don't use the eye word in front of my
face it's not okay to say things
oh and don't say it at all yeah
but and keep your mouth shut and mind
your own business
yeah it's it is it is not okay to say
things
with kids right well it doesn't dream
well i would say just go over and say
hello aws of a
birthday it doesn't bother me too much
but when like a friend drives you
somewhere and they use like personal
words that something else can get out
i think people should be in that word
and
instead of saying that r word have the r
word be respect
i am in a relationship
bringing lansing with my friends is
pretty cool i'm disagreeing because
i had lots of exes and sometimes i won't
treat myself being single the reason why
i picked so much degree is because i
found my love and someone that i care
about
and i'm really happy for that
and but sometimes it's hard to keep
my girlfriend happy um why is it hard to
keep her happy
because sometimes she could be like
once you guys angry she's usually hungry
for me personally i do have a girlfriend
but all girlfriends
us out there
be happy to have what you want
because
we are here
to
have
great guys to be great
in this is it with ladies
but ladies it's really tough right now
but
for me
i love my girlfriend
i earn my own money
um i went out my own money
that's why i got a job
the owner of the coffee shop really
likes me and i get my my own interview
and i got my own job to make
drinks and food
and ever since i dated him
it makes my heart very happy to see him
grow it's very rewarding to see what she
does
it makes me proud
i own the old money to be independently
not to live on your own and i make
t-shirts
i do earn
my
money i work hard i want to be a
billionaire and a millionaire as a woman
as down as down syndrome as myself
i do make my money i wrote my book and i
do public speaking and then i've been
doing a tv show called born this way i
worked really hard to be on the top
and that's what i am and i am very very
accessible career
woman and i make the way and
i go big and i don't go home
and i follow my dream that's true as
kids with special needs have dreams to
follow
no matter what dream it is
do what you can do the best
don't let anyone take you down
i love earning my own money feels great
to know that i have
i do a good job of working it makes me
feel happy that i did a great job
you know even though i have down
syndrome i earned that money because i
earn respect so people out there who
think we can't do it we can
and we're powerful strong and we're
going to do anything we put our minds to
grace do you want to share
she's doing this she's like making some
money making some money
that helps yeah sorry girl
i can help you out
i want to have children
[Applause]
i don't have a kid just yet
maybe i'm going to feel
there's the right time i want to have a
kid i will
but it's also hard
to do to care them
because of
what i have and it's hard for me to
get up in the morning to prepare lunch
for my kids and all that it's hard
so
i want to get to know who my who i am
right now and learn
i will love to have children
because i love children that i'm about
to play with like to play around with
them
do interview with them and i would love
to have kids to pay attention to each
other because they're all here to have
fun
i like babies a lot so
let the responsibilities take care of
the child so i'm going to be a great
mother and a great teacher that she can
have manners and
great and having fun and exploring their
education i just came over here to angry
i do want to have children i do want to
give my kid a wife and i want to raise
them as my own
but i do not want to depend on my mom
to raise my child by herself
i do want to have kids because i want to
give them the life that my mother gave
me
i can take care of myself
well i do take care of myself
um i'm really good at cooking and
cleaning after myself sometimes i'm not
very good by keeping my room clean
sometimes but i work on tours that i do
get independent um i don't like it
i am like an independent woman i like to
be with my friends i love to be with
boys of course because i'm boy crazy
and i like to go crazy and i like to
party
you see i'm very confident
i'm good at finding clothes
and
do some groceries to carry yourself like
self-caring
and helping people out and
make people laugh and
imitate from my comedy yep i'm going to
be instead of comedian
oh so you have jokes yes i do
i can take care of myself
this way
i
want want want what
help
she needs help with her back
good job
i love how i look
the reason why i say strongly agree is
because
because i love the way i look
i don't care what i look like i know
what i like
and i'm very happy for that
and i don't care what people think of me
i know i'm the best because
i love my body
i
am
but if i need i'm unique and i'm
beautiful and i am also independent
women
i love the way i look
because i am
gorgeous i am beautiful and strong and
fearless because i'm
fierce
for me
staying beautiful and being strong and
confident
you get some booze of your looks
and in the mirror and feel confident who
you are
well i love the look is my personality
my
greatness
personality because um
i am who i am but i love myself i do
but for me
it's really cool to be my friends is
here right now with me as these friends
i have right now because i feel so great
because i feel so powerful i have these
guns
because
i got a great smile to my friends right
here
i'm okay with having down syndrome
so i agree
here on this because
it makes me me and that my friends don't
trip me
here like i'm just simulating the kid
with down syndrome i'm happy for her for
who i am sometimes my family they
kind of baby me a little bit but if i'm
with my friends they don't try to baby
me as much and i'm happy for that so for
for that reason
i'm happy because they are happy me
having dieting gym is not really hard
for me
just being who i am
and it just makes me special
i
i am okay to be down syndrome because i
am not ashamed of who i am and what i
look like
because i am beautiful accessible
business confident career woman i am
really strongly agree about what i am
and don't be
ashamed i have done syndrome and i love
who i am because i am really
really thankful to myself i love myself
i love these guys to be my friends how
down syndrome not really attached to me
come here
i love to stay out here my friends i
love partying my friends
no matter what i do
even though i have a disability
i can still have fun no matter what
that's right
yeah
nightmare
parallel possible guys me too
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
that's right
he's killing it
right boy